hey guys how's it going interesting
we're here today for another Fed Ex
unboxing I received this package in the
mail FedEx like I had to track it down
and when you guys see what's inside of
here they were making me sign for this
package I had to sign for this now I'm
curious you don't know you don't know
what's in here yes we did tellin Tommy
we did it okay what is inside this box
is something that I actually did not
even know was for real it was rumored no
one thought that it was a thing but
guess what it's a thing and it is here
two days what it's gonna be really funny
if it's something completely different
and then you open it and it's like woven
it up dummy you ordered like a six pack
of straw oh Jesus I'm kind of torn I
know you normally do your unboxings by
yourself but that life is coming right
towards me it'd be a really short video
okay pull tab yeah but it was I don't
you think is in here wait a minute what
if it's something else
just one yes I guess what do you think
I'm so excited about on social media
today now I've got a little minute I
don't have no clue just one thing what
do you think I would be most excited
about it fits inside of this box it's an
Apple product hmm or think what's on
your counter look around
Mario character of some sort something
here let's bring them in for any man
after I open this up I also did an
unboxing of these which I filmed
probably like a month ago I never posted
so I'll post down to this video as well
but for the time being let's open this
up because I'm just wasting time I've
never seen a box open so inefficiently
no way what is that it is super mario
cereal did you see this online I've been
a rumor in it no this is it it's awesome
and guess what else
no Becca Nintendo's make it cereal got a
barcode and Hennessy but these are
amiibo invisible with this arm they
interact with games with that they give
you a ball and spoons one of my biggest
fears was that you weren't gonna have a
bowl when then comes alright given bowls
for the for all time what if I want to
taste it yeah that's why you brought
over milk like why are you putting milk
in my fridge oh I don't I don't need it
hold up with spoons a popsicle taste in
my mouth
so that is available as early as
December 11th because a partnership with
how long later I should put again in
story I'm so serious let's get a bowl
with like a real spoon mix berry cereal
with marshmallows oh wait let's see I'll
open it up oh no I ripped it she well my
bonus have no capability so basically I
can scan this box and I can import an
ebow I thought you like pour the cereal
on your Nintendo switch Wow of the
marshmallows oh I'll basically like
Lucky Charms
but mall over here cut the mallow now
you gonna be welcome at the same time oh
my gosh
Oh Musti but okay oh I mean it lucky
charm dump me some yeah
that was wrong Tina saber is a literary
lucky lucky charm is pulled like another
dinner
these are little Yoshi eggs I think I'm
assuming yeah Yoshi eggs is your little
question block Yoshi I'm sorry this is
so great I've eaten them all you know
fahren oh my gosh that's a perfect pour
you're supposed to pour the milk first I
said that I always see people on Twitter
making the comparisons like no I don't
even drink milk in my cereal I didn't
drink no you know what when I was eating
cereal I was super into almond milk on
my cereal
damn it in there hmm look at me coming
in from one side of the camera from
another its movie magic beef ball guys
it's just like Lucky Charms
yes sir it was a one-person job I don't
know how much I get I was like how fast
can you drink this milk ha ha
to be in that cereal that was delicious
oh my gosh I have cereal all right hit a
switch I gotta get to animal place here
so in the game oh my gosh that's dusty
with cereal buster Cyril does is it in
focus it is in focus you did okay we're
going up here chew the amiibo hey you
gotta me me bow I say yes I do if you
happen to have some put them to work
you're holding and now we tap Wow no way
let's see that oh it's a delicious
amiibo oh my god what is it gonna be
I'll send this delicious annual out to
look for a power moon I'm gonna take
about five minutes to look so come back
in a bit
what is the name of the kingdom that
Mario is known for saving the super
Kingdom the star kingdom the Mushroom
Kingdom the Koopa Kingdom mushroom
where's the question they get tricked
there's a bunch of questions which
character trait describes Mario
courageous shy mysterious or naughty I
say naughty definitely naughty who is
Mario's brother and trusted sidekick
Bowser Luigi toad or shy guy I should
mara Louise you were always just really
good friends they're brothers so the
Mario Brothers the Super Mario Brothers
oh oh my goodness oh my god what a
realization you have to drink the milk
my brother always made me be Luigi
honestly
Luigi's taller he's actually I'd say a
little bit more handsome it's the exact
opposite in real life Luigi's Mansion is
by far one of my most favorite games
city town Super Mario 64 the best Mario
game hands down I will not take any
other Super Mario Bros it was a great
game I was it wasn't that game of Mario
60 don't worry but Mario 64 you don't
understand how fun that game was my
brother and I would go over our
grandma's every since I was dating my
friend Kristen you should come over we
would play I beat Bowser for her
remember
no I oh my god hold on don't Bowser for
them yeah but I be Bowser up everything
else is no I'm sorry
remember how much fun Mario Party was
all the mario parties i minigames much
Mario Party to be honest with you I
didn't have any friends to play with so
yeah we have more colors now since I
would have been your friend
yeah be weighted more yeah like not
alive yeah like thought you're a little
too old well whatever
so Miami Belle was out shopping looking
for some power moon so he just does goes
and look you don't did anything well
yeah cuz I can hold it up in my map and
then I go and see like where I just want
to play Mario 64 now I'm telling you
what me and you should surely play
I haven't played Mario game on the
switch yet do you suggest it are you
kidding me what do you think I was doing
the whole time we were on vacation
Hawaii this is why I did not participate
in any she would not give me the game
you were playing start D value or
whatever and then this came out and then
I did nothing else what's that game
called start develop your Denali walk
she had a the Nintendo switch
I want to tap into
I did look I can tap another amiibo now
you're just bragging here time wait use
happen on the analog stick yeah oh my
goodness does he look a handsome man
delicious amiibo is back from looking
for hints this is so cool guy I'm so
freaking excited about this I'm so
excited that all my friends have left me
and lost track of what I like you
believe Mario is wearing a wedding dress
oh my gosh what am I gonna wear a Bowser
tuxedo that's all right oh yeah look at
that tux yeah baby you look great look
he's got like a little balls or shell on
his back I didn't unboxing a while ago
of these amiibo but I never posted it so
I'm gonna clued that here in this video
don't here we go let's go unbox these
and evil that I'm holding right now
let's start with Bowser this game is
just unbelievable
kind of love the smell of fresh amiibo
he is a hefty beast oh he's got like a
shiny pearl iridescent suit next up
we're saving Princess Peach for last
Mario my homie there's so many costumes
that you can get in this game like thick
I don't even know because I haven't
looked it up like what the actual 100%
completion of this game looks like I
don't know many of you guys spoil
anything in the comments I'm gonna be
very very upset I will hide your comment
for my channel I could do such a great
job at avoiding spoilers
look at my boy Mario he is stuntin like
a something I really do like that their
theme was purple and this iridescent
pearl because purple is one of my
favorite colors also pink is one of my
favorite colors also black and white and
like shades of grey not 50 just like 3
or 4
she's also got like glitter in her dress
and in her veil oh my goodness it's
beautiful
this is this is I I don't do cosplay but
I'm contemplating it now
peach girl you'd look like a million
bucks thank you guys so much for
watching you guys enjoy this let me know
if you guys are out in the wild and you
find one of these you'll be able to find
them in stores on December 11th and huge
thank you Dan Tendo for sending me this
early I'm so excited because man this is
like my childhood do things that I loved
Lucky Charms and Mario all-in-one Wow me
definitely doesn't like sharing I don't
want Terry not much has changed
cause I heard the child you have a hat
on make sure you go check out Matt's
channel he is nadeshot and go check out
Jenna it's me Joey
thank you guys for participating in my
video and thanks for having a delicious
taste test of the new super mario cereal
it's really good I ate a log of the
marshmallows I'm very sorry I think you
guys are gonna love this I'm really good
okay that's it
one two three Fox let me roll baby
yeah he's out we've got talent we've got
skills
Oh No stop recording
[Music]